all right Oscar winner Natalie Portman
has been a big Hollywood name for nearly
25 years she captivated audiences when
she was 12 in her first film Leone the
professional Portman has starred in
wide-ranging movies like Star Wars The
Phantom Menace and Black Swan and Jackie
she's also a longtime activist for
interval rights and the environment her
new documentary eating animals explores
the rise of so-called
factory farming in America and some of
the potential alternatives to meet the
movie is an adaptation of the 2009
best-selling book by the same name
filmmaker spoke with industry experts
and advocates about our country's eating
habits people are not eating me because
of how its produced they're eating me
despite how it's produced
yes people eat a lot of meat now but
once people are given two choices and
one of them is healthier and
environmentally sustainable and doesn't
harm animals and the other one is what
factory farming and slaughterhouses look
like I think we're gonna see massive
shift over to the plant-based
technologies the US Department of
Agriculture says in a statement a
successful agricultural industry is
vital to our nation the average age of
farmers is increasing and USDA is
focused on helping ensure the success of
new farmers joining this vital industry
to continue the legacy of caring for our
land and forests and producing the food
and fiber upon which our nation depends
Natalie Portman is a producer and
narrator voice is great on this narrator
of eating animals good morning and thank
you for joining us and we're table yeah
great party here Moni it really is I
watched it it made me nauseous a couple
times but this is what got to me and
I'll say I am a meat-eater meat industry
that you say in the doc has done a good
job of disconnecting eating meat from
killing animals when you eat meat an
animal has been murdered and I was
watching and eating a cheeseburger okay
let me just take that in for a second
because what you want us to know about
this documentary you're not wagging a
finger at those of us who eat meat but
you want us to be aware of the
consequences and what is happening here
specifically factory farming and I had
no idea what that is what that was well
I think that reading the book that this
movie was based on for me was so
eye-opening because he starts it with
Jonathan Safran Foer wrote the book is
writing letters to these companies
producing the meat saying can I see how
the meat is produced because I want to
know whether to feed it to my kids or
not which is you know if you called
Welch's grape juice or Lay's potato
chips they take you on a tour of their
Factory and it's completely closed the
meat industry you cannot see behind the
curtain and you can't even talk about it
in certain states there's laws where
you're not even allowed to talk about
what goes on and it's because it's it
would be appalling to any of us and it's
99 point something percent it's almost
all meat is
this way and dairy and eggs what would
we be appalled about well the the
conditions are like factories they're
factory farms it's not when we think of
a farm we think grass and a barn and a
farmer this is mass-produced animals and
very very tight conditions millions
together and not not being able to roam
it and that's what the film makes clear
and what it shows and also what they
feed the chickens and the turkeys to
make them so large the one fact that was
so stunning was that a baby would be 600
pounds if it was fed and given the same
things right but I thought I think his
name was Frank the turkey farmer was
interesting because to Gales point
you're saying there are farmers trying
to do it kind of the old-fashioned way
so that meat eaters can eat responsible
meat that isn't creating the toxic
runoff and all of that it's actually
quite a conservative argument like the
people who used to do it well the real
farmers the American farmers
salt-of-the-earth people are not being
supported and it's a really corporate
system that's pushing them out and
creating a very inhumane way of creating
our food and it's also polluting it's
the number one contributor to pollution
more than cars I mean if you care about
the environment you should care about
factory farming and you know changing
farming practices so what is the
alternative
for well there's really great first of
all I think it's unrealistic that people
are gonna completely change their
lifestyle and eating habits we can cut
down though exactly I think being
conscious once a day or once a week and
just experimenting with what does it
look like if one meal a day
I don't eat me whatever what is it one
day a week and then also there are
really great replacement things now
there's great replacement meats there's
the impossible burger there's beyond me
there's replacement cheeses and and
there's you know all these like cheese
and dairy and yogurt and made out
nuts or coconut milk or no it's very
eye-opening and I think very educational
I think it's that people should watch it
just because you'll learn a lot and it
will get you thinking about things that
you might not have considered before I
want to talk about Harvey Weinstein for
a second because you were very vocal
very one of the leaders of the times
that movement when you saw him in
handcuffs Napoli what did you think well
I think it was you know unfortunately
you there's not a win in this situation
so many people have been so hurt but
it's it is important for us to see that
there's consequences even for the most
powerful of the abusers there were there
will be consequences and and I think
that's important I went back in looks
there's like what Weinstein movies or
Miramax movies was Natalie Portman in
and it was that 96 drama beautiful girls
and your co-stars were uma Thurman
Lauren Holly and Mira Sorvino I know I
was I when so many of those women came
forward it was crazy to think I was 13
years old on a set where I although all
the women around me were being really
really hurt and I was lucky to be
oblivious to to that but it's it was I
think such a big wake-up call of course
for all of us and and yes and I'm I'm
glad that there's consequences but
unfortunately I wish it just didn't
happen and and hopefully the
consequences will prevent and deter
other other people from abusing their
power and the conversation continues
Natalie Portman wonderful to have you in
years so much thank you for being here
and eating animals is in select theaters
today we have reached out to several
councils and associations in the meat
and farming industries and their
statements are posted on CBS this
morning calm